I'm tasked with updating everybody on acalabrutinib in terms of the data this year at ASH. Actually,
there were a couple of practice-changing, at least to me, practice-changing abstracts,
so I'll highlight some of them. First, just to put it in perspective, this is old data. Actually, I
reviewed this last year here at this conference, the ElevateTN dataset, the three-arm study
establishing superiority of acalabrutinib venetoclax with or without orbinutuzumab
in terms of improvement in progression-free survival in comparison to
investigative choice in treatment-naive patients. This is a very effective strategy. A lot of
I like using it, and in fact, I'll just highlight also something important that,
even though it was not part of the primary analysis for this study, there's a trend toward
overall survival benefit in favor of the triple combination, which is important, obviously, in
terms of the value for our patients, but also it highlights that it matters what you do in front
line. A lot of us in chronic disease, a disease like this where patients are relapsing and
remitting and require other lines of therapy, we usually think that perhaps they can be salvaged
in subsequent lines of therapy, but in fact, here, at least the trend toward overall survival
benefit suggests that, again, it matters what you do in front line and long term. Now, this
strategy is very effective, but unfortunately, as you can see on the right-hand side, it comes with
significant toxicity in terms of infection complications, nearly doubling the infection
complications of the triplet in comparison to the doublet, and also cytopenia. So, this year at ASH,
the MD Anderson folks actually presented data, and this was interesting to me and important,
I think. So, this is evaluating, it's a randomized phase two study of acalabrine plus venetoclax, but
the question was really early versus late institution of obinutuzumab therapy. The treatment
schema is on the right-hand side, so everybody was randomized to receive either obinutuzumab early
in the course, as the L of ATN, or later in the course. For those patients that received
or were randomized to the obinutuzumab, they first got obinutuzumab for the first month,
then they went on to receive acalabrutinib in the second month and beyond,
and in the third month, venetoclax was introduced with the usual ramp-up and tumor lysis management.
For those that did not get randomized to the early obinutuzumab arm, they started with two months
of acalabrutinib and then went on to receive venetoclax. And at 14 months post-initiation of
this regimen, there was a question of MRD assessment and response assessment, and those
patients that met criteria were on the late obinutuzumab arm, or those patients that required
any treatment based on MRD assessment had the option of proceeding with later course of
obinutuzumab at that juncture. The primary endpoint here was really evaluating bone marrow MRD
improvement. This is the study population. It's a fairly standard population. By the way,
this study was restricted to high-risk patients with IGVH mutation, P53 mutation,
that kind of a thing. And what I'll highlight here on the left-hand side in the panel, you can see,
at the end of either the doublet or treatment therapy, this is the end of cycle 14,
you can see bone marrow undetectable MRD. In the doublet, or the no, or sorry, the late
obinutuzumab arm, the MRD is 26% versus the triplet is 71%. In the entire population,
as you can see on the very, very bottom there on the left-hand side, 78% of the patients that
were on the late obin arm went on to receive obinutuzumab in the late fashion. And by the time
you get to the end of cycle 26, again in the top panel there, actually both arms have equivalent
undetectable MRD. So with late institution of obinutuzumab, you actually can get the same degree
of undetectable MRD. And you can, looking at CR rates by radiographic and clinical criteria,
essentially equivalent whether you do early or late obinutuzumab. On the right-hand side is the
undetectable MRD for high-risk disease, namely unmutated IgVH, and it mirrors the same data.
At the end of cycle 14, they're substantially higher in the early obinutuzumab arm, 75% versus
26%. But when you go down to the end of cycle 26, by which point both groups have received
obinutuzumab, you can see equal rates of undetectable MRD. And in fact, this is also
reflected here. 78% of the patients at the end of cycle 14 in the doublet arm
actually were still MRD-positive, and those 51% were MRD-positive in the bone marrow,
went on to receive obinutuzumab. 15 out of 17 were undetectable MRD. And for the sake of time,
I'll just highlight that really the pattern continues in other categories here.
Now, in terms of the toxicity, and that's what's valuable here, there's actually a trend that in
the triplet or early obinutuzumab arm, there are higher deaths. This is related to COVID. This was
done in the context of COVID pandemic, and so there were more deaths in the Acala/obinutuzumab Venn arm
here. And in fact, looking at the toxicity, indeed, we do see significantly more toxicity here in the
early obinutuzumab versus late obinutuzumab arm as manifest as infection complications. In terms of
grade three complications, 26% versus 5% here, and also same thing for thrombocytopenias.
And in terms of the later phase, really, once you institute the obinutuzumab even in the later phase,
actually, you don't see a substantial increase in infection complications. And this is also mirroring
and I'm running out of time here, but again, highlighting exactly the same thing that I've
already alluded to in regards to the lower infection complications in a late obinutuzumab
arm. So that to me is practice changing in the sense that if you're using this strategy, I think
probably the best is to consider late institution of obinutuzumab.
Now, in the limited time that I have, I'll highlight one other study. This is mirroring the
FLARE study. This is a planned study for patients with older that have previously untreated CLL,
but have high SEER scores or impaired renal clearance. There was a planned discontinuation
of acalabrutinib monotherapy after 18 months of therapy. And for those patients that later
progressed, they could reinstitute therapy with acalabrutinib again. And here, not surprisingly,
the patients that discontinue actually fairly quickly continue to progress. So highlighting
what has already been seen that in single agent BTK inhibitors, I think the planned discontinuation
is not a good strategy. However, if you look at the IGVH mutated group, actually here, I don't
know where they got the 18 months of therapy, but it actually looks like at least in that category
of patients, you can potentially consider, and remember, this is older patient populations, a lot
of comorbidities, there is a risk of arrhythmias and other complications. So at least in that
category, very cautiously, you can potentially consider in the mutated IGVH treatment interruption.
So I'll stop there.